It's lunch time at this soup kitchen in New York city...
...and the turnover at the tables is brisk.
Part of the Solution or POTS...
...is widely known in the Bronx as the friendliest soup kitchen in the borough...
...and there are lines at the door for hours.
We get people that're working...
...and they come over to eat lunch because they can't afford that $7 to $10 a day...
...so they can come in and eat for nothing.
And save that money.
Michael Kennedy has a job at the nearby cinema and eats at POTS five times a week.
He found it hard at first to swallow his pride and ask for help...
...but says the soup kitchen is a powerful equalizer.
I'm well beyond the point of not me, not I, you know?
I'm beyond that, I'm like everybody else...
...and again, it doesn't really make any difference who you are and what you once were.
The reality of it is that I needed to come here...
...to get help with housing, to get help with Medicaid,...
...to get help with food stamps, and to get a meal.